so you say i i've met this person that i
really like how do i build trust well
you don't tell them all your secrets on
the first day right um we all know that
you have to be vulnerable but but there
is there is a there's a timing you know
and it's a dance and it's and it's
giving somebody a little extra um uh
responsibility and seeing how they do
and if they screw up instead of yelling
at them be like all right try again you
know that we treat mistakes as learning
opportunities rather than you know and a
mistake is only when you keep repeating
the same error and you haven't learned
anything
um
where
we practice empathy you build trust with
empathy as well so um
empathy uh in business looks like this
um here's a traditional
scenario um
somebody walks you know picks up the
phone or walks into their office when we
had when we did that
and says
you know your numbers are down for the
third quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before
and if you don't pick up your numbers in
the fourth quarter i don't know what's
going to happen right that's pretty
normal here's empathy injected into that
scenario hey your numbers are down for
the third quarter in a row we've had
this conversation before
um are you okay i'm worried about you
what's going on
right
where it's about the person not the
performance
and so when again it goes back to that
listening and you you are not listening
until somebody else feels heard those
things you know seeing someone as human
understanding that we all have stresses
and strains and egos and insecurities
and we bring all of that to work
and though we still have to be uh
emotionally professional you know you
can't sit in a meeting like this because
you're having a bad day that's
emotionally unprofessional
um though we still have to be
emotionally professional um we're still
human beings yeah
and a good leader uh recognizes that
and by the way somebody on a team
recognizes that too you don't have to be
a position of authority to be a good
leader you know because those who may be
higher in rank than us are also filled
with insecurity and fear and stress and
strain and ego and all that right and
it's okay to go up the chain of command
and say hey are you okay you know you
were really hard on us
in that meeting today
instead of labeling them an [ __ ] be
like are you are you okay
you know and and by the way and that's
the dance it's like any relationship you
know it's not expected for one person in
an interpersonal relationship to to do
all the listening it it's a dance and it
goes backwards and forwards and you know
you you you meet empathy with empathy
and you meet listening with listening